J'ai pas dormi depuis deux jours... Ah, les amis j'ai découvert une histoire formidable !!
Connaissez-vous l'histoire du pain maudit de Pont-Saint-Esprit ?
Vous en avez peut-être déjà entendu parler, puisque ces derniers mois l'affaire est sortie un peu dans quelques médias
et surtout elle fait sensation parce que le mystère n'a toujours pas été expliqué. De quel mystère vais-je parler ?
Attendez, soyez patients😁😁, commençons l'histoire : connaissez-vous la ville de Pont-Saint-Esprit ?
moi je connaissais pas avant cette histoire pour être franc avec vous.
Il s'agit d'une petite ville du sud de la France, en 1950 il y avait environ 4000 habitants
Il y avait trois médecins ce qui est pas beaucoup : ça fait un médecin pour 1000 personnes.
Faut pas avoir une angine en même temps !
C'est assez rural, ça vit essentiellement de la viticulture et la ville est très connue pour son pont.
Tellement connue pour son pont, que le mot "pont" est même dans le nom de la ville.
Pourquoi le pont est connu ? Parce que l'histoire raconte, qu'il aurait été construit par le Saint-Esprit,
contre la volonté du diable, qui ne voulait pas qu'il y ait de pont. Alors, je pense que si ces deux entités
existent, elles s'en battent un peu les couilles d'un pont, après c'est mon avis mais...
Petit problème : le pont a été bombardé par les américains
pendant la guerre, et du coup il y a plus de pont. Donc les habitants, les spiritains je crois ils s'appellent, les spiritinis.... Merde !
Ils sont plus trop fiers parce que ce fameux pont est détruit, même si ils en construisent un
provisoire mais voilà, tout ça c'est juste pour contextualiser un peu ce que c'est que cette ville, d'où elle sort, ce qui s'y passe etc...
On va maintenant s'intéresser à des faits qui sont survenus, dans les années 50, dans la ville et qui sont
passionnants le 2 août 1951 plusieurs personnes vont chez le médecin et se plaignent de douleurs
gastriques et de malaise même pour certains. Bon, c'est symptômes pas très graves qui peuvent arriver
pour plusieurs raisons. Le médecin conclut qu'il y a eu une intoxication alimentaire, donc il leurs prescrit une tisane de grand mère, et puis ça
devrait aller mieux, sauf que c'est pas le cas. La situation
s'aggrave, quand quatre cinq jours plus tard, 100 personnes vont se mettre à manifester les mêmes symptômes.
et en plus, petites nouveautés dans les symptômes : il y en a qui en plus de ça font des insomnies, mais ça va de la petite insomnie
à l'énorme insomnie. Il y a un témoignage d'un monsieur, qui lui va dire que son insomnie elle n'a pas duré une nuit, ni deux,
ni trois, elle a duré vingt-et-une nuits, lui, il a fait 21 nuits sans dormir.
Normalement tu te mets à péter un câble et à avoir des hallucinations. Ah ! retenez ce mot : "hallucinations" vous allez voir il va revenir !
Bref, des dizaines de personnes font des insomnies, normalement pour Saint-Esprit c'est une petite ville à 22 heures tous les gens dorment,
mais là c'est pas le cas, là tu sors dans les rues et tu peux croiser beaucoup de gens qui font des insomnies, et qui parlent tous seuls,
qui sont en plein délire, et on ne sait pas pourquoi, on sait pas ce qui se passe.
Petit à petit un autre symptôme fait son apparition, les gens commencent à avoir des hallucinations.
Certains vont avoir la sensation de brûler de l'intérieur, et vont se jeter dans le Rhône, pour éteindre le feu qui n'existe pas.
Il y en a plein qui pensent être capables de voler, et qui vont se jeter de leurs fenêtres... Bref, des hallucinations
horribles qui mènent certaines personnes du village à la mort. La ville est prise de panique. Le bilan de tout ça c'est 300 personnes qui ont eu des
hallucinations, dont 7 qui sont mortes, et dont 50 qui ont été internées dans un hôpital psychiatrique
Qu'est ce qui a causé ça ? Alors face à ça, les médecins ils perdent un peu leurs moyens, ils comprennent pas ce qui se
passe. En plus je le rappelle, ils sont que 3.
L'infrastructure de Pont-Saint-Esprit elle est clairement pas faite pour gérer 300 personnes qui font un Bad Trip
en même temps ! Cette nuit là, les victimes elles sont de plus en plus nombreuses, et en plus elles sont de plus en plus
incontrôlables. C'est vraiment des gens qui sont dans la démence, qui délirent totalement, qui bougent dans tous les sens, qui hurlent ; et c'est là que
naît le mystère de pont-saint-esprit. Il y a donc une enquête qui est ouverte, et la première piste qu'on a, est
découverte par un professeur de médecine qui était en vacances au moment des faits, qui se rend à Pont-Saint-Esprit, et qui fait le rapprochement entre
les symptômes des victimes, et une vieille maladie, qu'on surnomme "le mal des ardents" ou
"le feu Saint-Antoine" qui est une maladie qui date du moyen âge, et qui avait apparemment complètement disparu. Il y a d'ailleurs pas mal de tableaux qui
montrent des scènes horrifiques, de gens qui sont victimes de cette maladie là. Alors le vrai nom de cette maladie, c'est pas "le feu
Saint-Antoine" qui est un surnom, parce que les victimes de la maladie ont l'impression de brûler de l'intérieur, c'est
l'ergotisme, le responsable de l'ergotisme, c'est l'ergot du seigle, qui est un champignon qui va se mettre sur la céréale et quand tu l'ingères,
tu vas avoir des symptômes très similaires, à ceux qu'ont eus les habitants de la ville de Pont-saint-esprit le 24 août
1951. L'enquête va ensuite montrer que toutes les victimes de ces symptômes, ont un point commun : Elles ont acheté leurs pains dans la même boulangerie.
Est-ce que le pain aurait été confectionné à partir de farine
contaminée par l'ergo de seigle ? C'est
possible, surtout vu le contexte on vient de sortir la seconde guerre mondiale, la France elle en pleine famine c'est une galère de nourrir tout
le monde donc la ressource principale c'est redevenu le pain cette piste de la contamination par l'ergot de seigle
semble être la bonne.Le commissaire Sigot de la police judiciaire de Montpellier est chargé de l'enquête
et va donc aller vers la boulangerie qui semble avoir vendu le pain tous ses habitants petit bémol les boulangers ne
choisissaient pas leur meunier c'est à dire qu'ils recevaient de la farine d'un meunier qui leur étaient attitré ils savait pas d'où ça venait donc c'est
pas de sa faute là. Le commissaire Sigot il est malin il y en a dans le ciboulot il va retrouver le minotier qui a confectionné
cette farine
monsieur Maillet, il va l'interroger
bien brusquer à tel point que monsieur Maillet va faire des aveux alors qu'il n'a rien à se reprocher; vous savez les enquêtes ou c'est très
très médiatisé, où il y a beaucoup d'enjeux on veut absolument trouver un coupable quitte à ce que quelqu'un fasse
des aveux alors que c'est pas lui le coupable on s'en fout mais il faut qu'il y ait un coupable aux yeux de la presse et de
la population jusque là tout va bien le mystère est résolu
sauf que un mois plus tard l'expertise
innocente monsieur Maillet parce que les farines ont été analysées et il n'y a pas d'ergot de seigle dans ces dernières et là c'est
très frustrant parce que l'affaire s'arrête là.
Il y a plein de pistes mais elles mènent à rien et les habitants de Pont-Saint-Esprit n'ont pas de réponses à leurs questions ils sont comme des cons
étonnemment on va pas reparler de l'affaire pendant
60 ans c'est seulement en
2010 que quelqu'un va reparler de l'affaire et c'est pas un français, c'est un américain qui s'appelle Hank Albarelli et qui enquête à ce
moment là sur la mort, dans les années 50, d'un biochimiste de la CIA Frank Olson.
Alors là vous allez me dire : mais où est le rapport Lucas on comprend plus là on sait plus
Attendez, ça arrive patience ! Frank Olson qui bosse pour la CIA est un spécialiste des drogues dures et mène de nombreuses expériences pour étudier
leurs effets dans le but d'en tirer profit et comme par hasard
Franck s'est rendu en France quelques mois avant la tragédie de Pont-Saint-Esprit peu de temps après son passage en France Frank entre dans une énorme
dépression et répète à sa femme qu'il a commis une terrible erreur et il décède dans les années
1953 sans qu'on sache ce qui voulait dire par "j'ai commis une terrible erreur". Peut-être
empoisonner un village qui n'a rien demandé Frank ? Fank qui, je le rappelle, enquête du coup sûr la mort de Frank va faire un
rapprochement et si la CIA avait pulvérisé du LSD sur le pain de Pont-Saint-Esprit dans le but d'en étudier les effets à grande échelle? Je
sais ce que vous pensez. Pour le moment ça vous paraît débile et inconcevable, mais attendez attendez j'ai des infos pour vous ! On va rentrer un
peu dans la chimie mais vous allez voir c'est là on se dit que cette idée elle ne paraît pas si conne qu'il faut savoir
que l'ergot de seigle contient des alcaloïdes dont un en particulier
celui de l'acide lysergique ça vous dit rien c'est normal, moi aussi mais il faut savoir que le LSD c'est un dérivé de l'acide
lysergique donc les effets de l'ergot de seigle et les effets du LSD sont très similaires.
ça vous paraît donc moins bête que les habitants de Pont-Saint-Esprit n'aient pas été empoisonnés à l'ergot de seigle mais aient
peut-être été drogués au LSD. Pourquoi pas mais ça manque de preuves.
J'arrive attendez ! Après la seconde guerre mondiale vous savez c'est la course à l'armement et à l'arme nucléaire plus particulièrement parce qu'on a peur on
vit dans la peur d'une troisième guerre mondiale du coup toutes les nations du monde veulent être prêtes au cas où ya une autre guerre
qui arrive. La CIA elle va être intéressée par la manipulation mentale et si on mettait fin à un conflit sans qu'il y ait combat juste en
arrivant à convaincre en manipulant mentalement l'adversaire les US pensent donc que les effets hallucinatoires du LSD sont la clé de la manipulation mentale et
qui est chargé de tester les effets du LSD et d'en tirer les conclusions ? Frank Olson ! Alors je suis d'accord avec vous
c'est un peu abusé de tester les effets du LSD sur une ville entière mais il y'a des documents déclassifiés qui montrent qu'en
1950 les Etats-Unis ont fait des tests du même genre à San Francisco. Il y a un navire américain qui a bombardé la ville pour tester
les effets d'une bactérie a eu douze personnes hospitalisées dont une qui est morte à cause de ça tout ça bien sûr dans le but
de se préparer à une éventuelle nouvelle guerre. Les enquêteurs qui sont chargés de l’enquête de Pont-Saint-Esprit font le rapprochement entre les effets de l'ergot
de seigle et du LSD ils vont donc contacter le créateur du LSD, Albert Hofmann pour qu'il vienne à Pont-Saint-Esprit
confirmer si c'est des effets du LSD ou si c'est des effets de l'ergot de seigle et devinez quoi  ?
Selon lui c'est clairement des symptômes liés au LSD. Ah ?!? L'enquête avance, c'est bien, c'est satisfaisant quand l'enquête avance, vous avez vu ?
Attendez ! Elle va très vite arrêter d'avancer, quelques jours plus tard Albert Hofmann revient sur ses propos et dit qu'il s'est trompé que tout ça
n'était pas lié au LSD mais à autre chose.
Mhh... les US t'auraient pas mis un petit coup de pression Albert ? Est-ce qu'Albert s'est vraiment trompé ? Est ce que c'était vraiment l'ergot de seigle qui
était responsable de tout ça et pas du LSD ? Bah là pour le moment moi je penche plus vers l'ergot de seigle clairement, mais attendez c'est pas
la fin !
C'est passionnant, nan sans déconner elle est folle
cette histoire ! Alors il faut savoir que la CIA pendant des décennies mène un programme où ils font des expériences
horribles et inhumaines sur des gens contre leur gré sauf que les expériences vont mener à rien et que petit à petit les victimes vont
sortir du silence donc tout le monde va commencer à savoir ce qui se passe cette situation va obliger Bill Clinton en
1995 à faire une déclaration dans laquelle il s'excuse auprès de toutes les victimes de ces programmes secrets, et à
déclassifier des documents de la CIA qui jusqu'à présent étaient secret défense.
Devinez qui va mettre son nez dans ces documents ? Hank !
Bah oui ça va peut-être l'aider à comprendre comment Frank Olson est mort. Hank trouve un document sur lequel on trouve et le nom de
Frank Olson et dans ce document, deux paragraphes parlent des événements tragiques de 1951 de Pont-Saint-Esprit et tous les paragraphes suivants sont eux
grimés de noir pour qu'on ne puisse pas les lire.
Merde ! Alors, est ce que c'est un hasard ou pas qu'un document parle et de Frank qui étudie les effets du LSD et de la
ville de Pont-Saint-Esprit ? On sait pas peut-être que Franck a tout simplement été au courant de ce qu'il s'est passé à Pont-Saint-Esprit et
a étudié tout ça en se disant c'est du LSD qui a causé ça, on va quand même regarder les effets que ça a eu,
même si ce n'est pas lui qui a donné le
LSD à Pont-Saint-Esprit. Petite cerise sur le gâteau, Hank il va trouver un autre document dans lequel un
employé du laboratoire Sandoz, le laboratoire pour lequel travaille Albert Hofmann qui a découvert le LSD,
échange avec un agent secret américain et dans ce document le dirigeant du laboratoire aurait avoué que les événements tragiques de Pont-Saint-Esprit ne seraient pas
liés à l'ergot de seigle mais bel et bien au LSD. Fake ou pas fake on ne saura jamais !
L'enquête aujourd'hui s'arrête ici, le mystère reste total
et c'est horrible parce qu'il y a quand même eu des morts c'était vraiment une catastrophe, on se rend pas compte mais c'était la folie là
bas à Pont-Saint-Esprit et ça n'avait rien de positif tout ce qui s'est passé. Déjà la drogue de base c'est de la merde mais qu'en plus
t'es drogué à ton insu alors t'as rien demandé et que t'as des effets mais hallucinants, c'est le cas de le dire ahahah !
Est-ce l'ergot de seigle, est-ce les américains qui testaient les effets du LSD à grande échelle,
on ne sait pas ! On a le cul entre deux chaises, comme ceci, et puis on ne sait pas vers laquelle aller !
Hop-là la CIA !
Nan, je sais, comme moi, vous avez envie d'aller vers la théorie la plus abusée, la plus scandaleuse, c'est notre cerveau humain hein qui
nous fait ça mais il faut rester objectif, en tout cas j'espère que vous aurez bien tout compris à l'histoire, que j'ai apporté des précisions
à ceux qui
étaient déjà au courant de l'affaire mais qui n'avaient pas toutes les infos, en tout cas j'espère que ça vous a plu cette histoire,
n'hésitez pas aimer la vidéo si c'est le cas c'est ni thread ni un truc, là j'ai tenté voilà de raconter une histoire mystérieuse, je me suis documenté
comme j'ai pu et franchement j'ai été passionné de ce truc là. Vraiment je trouve ça génial comme histoire ! Je vous fait plein de bisous je
vous dis à très vite dans une prochaine vidéo,
peut-être qui relate aussi des histoires mystérieuses comme ça et pas forcément des threads, je sais pas, c'est la première, peut-être, d'une longue série
on sait pas, je vous dis à très vite dans une prochaine vidéo, portez-vous bien, au revoir !
*Outro* et *musique*